or breaking news in the last few minutes
we've learned that the rmt has suspended
all upcoming strikes and so the r t has
suspended its Network relustrial action
it says the r t national executive
committee has taken the decision to
suspend all industrial action on network
realm following receipt of a new offer
from the employer so crucial information
there that they have had a new offer
from the employer and further updates
will be given on all aspects of the
national rail dispute in the coming days
or expecting more on that in the next
few days so the rmt has suspended all
Network Rel industrial action